as i prepare for the holly jolly season
i have been plumbing the depths of the
internet
i want to get all that dreadfulness out
before the wonderful
feasts and
christmas time but i was told that i'm
not really allowed to enjoy christmas
time this by that wonderful cultural
institution smooth radio which tells us
that there are some christmas songs that
are absolutely
unforgivably irredeemably
bad
problematic ist phobic you know the
drill and so we're going to go through
them i i can certainly guess one of them
but we're going to go through and i want
to keep as open in mind as i can to see
if i
can get behind the logic at all of
cancelling these christmas songs this is
brought to you by kamikodo knives more
from them in a second first
number one no surprise whatsoever baby
it's cold outside
you say the dean martin version they
don't like that
here's their reasoning quote if anyone's
questioning what has been put in their
drink it's probably best to call it a
night there has been a lot of debate
around this song and it's a level of
political correctness it's even been
banned by a radio station due to the
metoo movement following complaints from
listeners yeah of course this is the one
that we all would have guessed the
reason the libs think it's a song about
rape is because they don't understand
anything about
how men and women traditionally interact
to one another and they don't understand
anything about the
male pursuit of women and the women's at
least performance of modesty and they
don't recognize that men and women react
differently to sex and they don't
recognize that the woman is agreeing to
this when she says oh i really can't
stay she's not saying get me out of here
call the cops you know there's like a
lady-shaped hole in the wall she's
saying come on
oh i re oh i really shouldn't stay why
why do you think i should stay no no
really please i shouldn't come on but
she stays she doesn't stay because he
clubs her over the head and drugs her
she stays rather because they like each
other okay that was that one was obvious
all right we all knew that was gonna be
on the list number two i saw mommy
kissing santa claus
why is
why is it wrong for mommy to kiss santa
claus because she's cheating on daddy
maybe okay what's the reason says quote
the ultimate trauma for any child is
seeing their mother kiss santa claus
that's the ultimate trump i don't know
about that both interpretations of this
song are quite problematic one santa
claus exists and the child has just seen
it says they're a mother but they're
referring to a single child so the
gender neutral
uh singular pronoun is
he
or his or him not the gender neutral
there okay minor point a child just seen
his mother kiss santa claus uh we don't
think mrs claus would be too happy about
this number two santa claus is actually
the child's father in fancy dress and
this in itself is traumatic
no santa and getting a front row view of
mommy and daddy kissing
no thanks
you know i i can sympathize with this no
one ever wants to think about their
parents you know in a romantic way or
worse yet you know having an adulterous
affair with a jolly old elf from the
north pole
but i do think it's actually good in our
day and age to see mommy and daddy
like and perhaps even love one another
because we live in an age where
basically everyone's parents are
divorced or you're in a home where there
are not or there's not a mother and a
father or it's like one parent or it's
you know maybe there's like a throuple
and a goat or something so they're very
strange family arrangements so i i can't
get behind this this uh argument i think
that mommy kissing daddy and maybe even
mommy kissing santa claus is just fine
grandma got run over by reindeer
is number three
reason quote what should be a sad story
about a grandma dying at chris
about a grandma dying at christmas time
is actually a pantomime style murder
mystery involving too much eggnog
incriminating claw marks on her back
hoof prints on her forehead and a
grandpa who's looking suspiciously happy
that grandma got knocked out by a hoof
there's also no moral backbone to this
song they even contemplate the question
should we open up her gifts or send them
back now i
i do
see that there is some problem here
because
you know it is a grisly gruesome
homicide possibly even a murder we don't
know
but i don't think the song should be
canceled simply because maybe it's
grandma but maybe it's just auntie or
uncle or nephew or cousin but
the holiday time we love to see our
families but
sometimes our families can be a little
difficult to be around and i think that
the
letting off a little steam might perhaps
it's even conducive to health and
flourishing and festivity
now when you want to prepare that
wonderful christmas meal i would
strongly recommend you check out
kamikodo knives when guests come up to
my door this holiday season this is how
i'm going to greet them i'm going to
greet them holding up these two gigantic
knives to show off the incredible
japanese steel that they are made with
kamikoto makes great japanese steel
kitchen knives using more than 800 years
of traditional techniques from japan
each knife comes in a beautiful wooden
heavy duty box it makes sure that the
knives are stored safely and it makes
kamikodo a great gift each kamikoto
knife goes through a rigorous 19-step
process that takes several years from
start to finish to complete the expert
blade smiths forge and shape raw steel
into hardy blades polishing and
sharpening them
to an excruciatingly fine edge each
knife is individually inspected kamikoto
is so confident about their knives that
each knife comes with a lifetime
guarantee i really strongly recommend it
kamikoto is currently having a massive
christmas sale and on top of that sale
you can get an additional 50 off any
purchase you make
with discount code knowles canon wles so
click the link below
or go to kamikodo.com
knowles and use promo code knowles
canadawles
to save an extra 50 bucks today
okay number four all i want for
christmas is you by mariah carey i quote
so much for being a strong independent
woman this song is all about our dear
mariah carey wanting nothing more than a
man for christmas she's even asking
another man santa to get her said man
but a man won't solve all your problems
mariah and although this is one of our
favorite christmas songs the lyrics
could do with a little updating so i
agree that this song should be cancelled
but for basically the opposite reasons
one
for most young women out there who have
been raised on a steady diet of feminism
and told never to have any sort of love
or stability or a family and just go
work in a widget factory and do
spreadsheets for the rest of your life
you sh you should have a man yes all you
all you should want under that tree for
christmas is a man that you can have a
good stable loving relationship with
that is absolutely
100 true uh the reason to cancel this
song is that it's just
just awful it's so it is like nails on a
freaking chalkboard so this would be a
rarity oh i disagree with the logic but
i do agree
with the conclusion
number five santa baby i love santa baby
why should this be canceled firstly we
don't get why this is a flirty song did
you not hear about mommy kissing santa
claus these people they don't think
surely it's a little weird to flirt with
a bearded old man to get what you want
for christmas pause for a second if
we're now saying
that women
being a little flirtatious to get what
they want
is uh
totally
verboten and we can't then women are
never going to get anything again this
is one of the greatest tools in women's
arsenals
and these so-called feminists are trying
to have them give it up for no reason
secondly it's a little bit annoying
listening to someone go on about how
good they've been all year when they
asked for ridiculously extravagant gifts
in
exchange sure but that's that's how our
culture is we live in a culture of pride
and me me
and
self love and adulation
beyond any sort of propriety so
that song
totally represents that we live in an
increasingly materialist age
and the song the song is not earnest the
song is
joking about this sort of thing but in
our culture we don't joke about that
sort of thing
we're just all about ourselves but you
know what a man wrapped up in himself
makes a very small package
indeed
so we're only canceling one i agree
we're going to cancel 20 of the songs on
that list the rest they stay happy
advent
[Music]
[Music]